bonjour à tous l'invité de salissement
d'un andré lucrèce sociologue un cri
sociologue écrivain
bonjour bonjour nous allons aborder avec
vous l'héritage de fanon et nous virons
s'y sont mis s'agit toujours d'actualité
aujourd'hui
je signale que vous êtes aussi l'auteur
de nice est ridicule et frantz fanon et
les antis l'empreinte d'une pensée vous
allez animer jeudi soir une conférence
sur fans 18 heures sur le campus on né
le 6 décembre c'est donc aujourd'hui
précisément que l'on commémore le 55e
anniversaire de sa mort fanon médecin
psychiatre anticolonialiste militant de
la cause algérienne il se bat contre la
ligne à sion des peuples et en
particulier du peuple martiniquais en
fait il se bat pour la décolonisation de
l'esprit andry du christ oui d'abord
permettez-moi d'abord de saluer sa
mémoire
il ya en effet 55 ans qu'il est mort
dans une clinique qui se tient proximité
de washington au moment même d'ailleurs
sortait les damnés de la terre de ses
livres les plus essentiels et puis alors
je voudrais aussi saluer puisque nous
sommes en décembre la mémoire des trois
jeunes martiniquais et qui ont été tuées
en décembre center et fans ont
d'ailleurs est intervenu à propos de cet
événement le sang coule et aux antilles
le sang coule et aux antilles et ils
disaient mais prenez ces corps aller
dans toutes les les tous les quartiers
de fort-de-france et montrer les alcools
l accusé est exposée la wii en effet bon
femmes non vous vous l'avez dit
certainement le plus grand théoricien de
la colonisation et de la décolonisation
aussi par conséquent alors avec lui et
un autre homme qui est tout à fait
remarquable et qui lui est plutôt le
théoricien de l'impérialisme mais c'est
edward saïd qui te palestiniens
ce sont deux hommes absolument essentiel
mes fans on a cette caractéristique si
vous voulez qu'il a une pratique de
combattant très tôt d'ailleurs très tôt
il est parti il a quitté la matinée
qu'il avait 18 ans pour l'est et il
rejoint les forces françaises pour
combattre le nazisme sa mére d'ailleurs
et en pleurs quand il part sur le bateau
qui s'appelle l'origan et le confie un
métro man vinh celui qui va devenir
maître menville et qui sera toujours
l'éternel compagnon de fanon et donc il
le confie à amanvi parce que c'est un
jeune homme mais leur revient aussi très
déçu de cette guerre il revient
extrêmement déçu de cette guerre il dit
à quoi bon me bat qu'on le fermier
lui-même n'est pas conscience de ce pour
quoi on se bat et est donc cette guerre
en tout cas si vous voulez montre déjà
le courage de fanon parce que il est
qu'il reçoit la croix de guerre ce qui
n'est pas rien avec des félicitations
des palmes enfin bref tout tous les
honneurs il est blessé
ils l'ont dit c'est parce que il faisait
le va et vient finalement entre les
lignes pour porter soit des armes soient
des munitions donc aux combattants et
c'est ainsi sur ce point c'est un homme
absolument à venir mais se juge aussi
collectons le conte explique aussi je
crois qu il explique aussi le mécanisme
son mois de la colonisation qui consiste
à neil et l'homme en étouffant sa
culture son mode d'expression
aso à l'amener à se renier lui-même mais
écoutez votre question est excellente
parce que j'ai entendu dire dernièrement
que la colonisation est un partage de
culture partage de tout on est donc
je veux que je voudrais dire que
précisément ce que fanon démontre c'est
que si culture il ya c'est une culture
de l'asservissement et donc par
conséquent il n'y en qu'un partage parce
que au contraire aux comptes tout à fait
au contraire l'asservissement entraîne
l'affrontement et en particulier la
révolte de ceux qui subissent cet
asservissement
donc il est effectivement le théoricien
de l'aliénation et sadeer va être
l'objet de de ma conférence lors de judy
soir vous avez vous avez un peu là vous
l'avez abordé une pensée toujours
d'actualité quand on entend certains
politiques français sarkozy dix ans nos
ancêtres les gaulois fillon l'esclavagé
partage de culture lisons peau noire
masques blancs et vous verrez que
justement fans on parle précisément de
cette aliénation ou toujours touche de
toute une cédule série de figures que
l'on voudrait nous imposer notamment la
la figure de nos ancêtres les gaulois
qui est une figure absolument grotesque
pas seulement grotesque d'ailleurs pour
les martiniquais et des guadeloupéens
mais également grotesque pour la france
elle même dit il y à des bretons il y à
des alsaciens il y à toute une série de
2,2 et des deux régions qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les gauloises c'est une
absurdité
de plus la france toujours nostalgique
que des des fameux bienfaits de la
colonisation
oui et c'est pour ça que flat fans ont
dit la chose suivante il dit ne me m'ont
pas l'europe l'europe a en quelque sorte
oublier l'homme a oublié cette chose
essentielle et senna l'humanise que
l'humanise le fan on commence enfin on
dit je veux marcher avec l'homme mais
avec tous les hommes et donc
contrairement à ce que certains peuvent
penser fanon était quelqu'un qui avait
une conception absolument universelle si
vous voulez de l'humanisme et ça c'est
une chose qu'il faut affirmer réaffirmé
c'est sa fin annoncée sur ge contre la
pensée alors ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la pensée unique
tout à fait tout à fait et cette pensée
unique
aujourd'hui si vous voulez se déclinent
ne pas inquiéter non
de l'infirmation comme celle dont on
parlait tout à l'heure nous en cette
ligue gaulois la colonisation partage de
culture et bien d'autres et ce qui est
absolument dommage c'est que si vous
voulez il y à certains qui se laisse
embarquer là dedans pour coiffer nom est
aussi peu connu en martinique que ne je
ne dirais pas cela
enfin non et et quelques de 2,2 si vous
voulez qui est une véritable référence
en revanche c'est vrai que il y a eu en
quelque sorte cette rupture avec la
martinique puisque les les faits les
événements l'ont amené à blida alors
qu'il souhaitait prendre son premier
poste de ski 4 donc à la martinique
ça n'était pas possible parce que le
seul poste qui était occupé qu'il était
par le dr liste des spins ouakid
ailleurs souhaitait la venue de faim non
parce qu'ils se connaissaient très bien
ils avaient travaillé ensemble en dans
l'hexagone et donc par conséquent il ya
eu cette rupture il est parti en algérie
à blida
il a soigné à la fois des algériens mais
également les bourreaux les délais ce
qui torturait les algériens pendant la
guerre d'algérie et qui n'arrivait pas à
dormir parce qu'ils avaient encore dans
la tête les cris n'est ce pas de ce
qu'ils torturaient pourquoi on approche
de la fin
pourquoi y ont donc je saute question
des eaux pour arriver à celle de la
relation cr fanon pourquoi on a essayé
de poser fanon à césaire d'autant plus
que fan on s'est inspiré de césaire et
que six heures a rendu hommage à fanons
l'on parle du guerrier silex tranchant
réis le faire les barreaux de prison les
regards des mots pour que ces airs fanon
est essentiel il dit
c'est une phrase de cr fanon est
essentielle à notre horizon d'hommes et
c'est une affection qui ne s'est jamais
démenti alors bien sûr il ya eu des
critiques fanon disais mais pourquoi
vous continuez à faire de la politique
comme ça
aux antilles et il était assez critique
vis-à-vis de cette politique qui au fond
10 et ils ne posaient pas les vrais
problèmes qui le problème
alain fois de l'année nation et de la
colonisation mais cette 7e et vous
l'avez dit cette relation est et noah
nation un peu si vous voulez tumultueuse
mais toujours affectueuse et l'hommage
le plus bel hommage qui a été rendu à
fanons il celui de crs que pour fanon
cette interrogation sur la condition du
noir et de son annulation est une
réflexion sur le moyen de sa libération
bien sûr bien sûr monsieur ce que dit ce
que dit fan on sait que il dit leblanc
esclavagisés le noir mais en même temps
le noir sur un esclave finalement du
blanc par cette aliénation
merci andré lucrèce sens qu'à déterminer
bonne journée à tous